[Música]
pese a ser prácticamente un conflicto
olvidado para la comunidad internacional
la guerra en yemen que se ha prolongado
por casi una década parece haber llegado
a un punto de coyuntura importante que
podría definir el fin de este conflicto
al menos así lo ha dicho la Organización
de las Naciones Unidas qué caracteriza
entonces a esta coyuntura veamos yemen
está atravesando un periodo de relativa
calma se mantiene en las tensiones se
mantienen también algunos ataques pero
lo que es cierto es que sí hay una leve
reducción del accionar militar en las
últimas semanas después de varios meses
de estar bajo amenaza de una posible
hambruna también el suministro de
combustibles de alimentos y de objetos
comerciales se ha mantenido en los
diferentes comercios a lo largo de las
últimas semanas Incluso se mantienen los
vuelos comerciales a diferentes
aeropuertos del país incluido el de saná
la capital yemení también recientemente
hubo un intercambio de cerca de 900
prisioneros
con 21 millones de habitantes es testigo
de una gran catástrofe humanitaria dos
tercios de la población necesita ayuda
humanitaria 17 millones de yemeníes la
necesitan de manera urgente Cuál es
Entonces el balance de esta guerra pues
como el de todo conflicto un balance
negativo porque una guerra Pues no va a
dejar algo positivo directamente está
relacionado con el grado de lo absurdo
que puede llegar a ser una guerra pero
380.000 personas han fallecido a lo
largo de los años en este conflicto
85.000 de estos personas fallecidas eran
menores de edad han fallecido también
por los combates por el hambre por las
enfermedades 4 millones de desplazados
dejaste conflicto hasta ahora y eso sí
destrucciones de ciudades poblaciones e
infraestructura en un país que ya estaba
entre uno de los más pobres del mundo
de acuerdo con este panorama Entonces
cuál es el futuro de esta guerra en
yemen el acercamiento entre Irán y
Arabia Saudita es un paso entonces en
una dirección hacia un cese de
hostilidades para comenzar digamos a
negociar esa pasta anhelada por este
país que puede hacer la comunidad
internacional en este conflicto en el
que como no están involucrados
directamente ni la Unión Europea ni
Rusia ni Estados Unidos pues no tienen
el mismo alcance mediático pero aquí en
France 24 si le vamos a dar despliegue a
este conflicto puede entonces yemen
tener un desenlace diferente a otros
países que han vivido o que viven un
conflicto estamos hablando de países
cercanos como el Líbano Irak Libia o
Siria
lo vamos a analizar hoy en el debate de
France 24 y para conversar sobre este
tema está con nosotros Alejandra Galindo
ella es profesora titular de la
Universidad de Monterrey se conecta
justamente Desde esa ciudad en el norte
de México allí en el estado de Nuevo
León y desde la ciudad de Barcelona en
España tenemos a Pamela Urrutia ella es
investigadoras de cultura de paz de la
Universidad Autónoma de Barcelona
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
instagram allí no se encuentran como
arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f-24 a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como @santilogo y les recuerdo
que todos los contenidos de este
programa también están disponibles en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y en
TuneIn
comenzamos Entonces el análisis y le doy
la bienvenida entonces Alejandra en la
ciudad de Monterrey en México Alejandra
Gracias por estar con nosotros
Bienvenida al programa primera pregunta
a Punto de partida para para este
análisis para este debate esta llamen de
verdad cerca de comenzar un proceso de
diálogo o por lo menos empezar a
plantear una ruta que lleve a la paz
Muchas gracias primero que nada por la
invitación y los felicito por tocar este
tema la guerra de yemen que como bien
decías al principio ha sido una guerra
olvidada con todas estas casualidades en
términos de muerte en términos de
generación perdidas todo lo que has
mencionado en infraestructura y yo
quisiera iniciar con algo positivo y
diciendo que a lo mejor sí esto puede
ser el comienzo para un proceso de paz
que se acerque cuando menos a pues una
paz definitiva Claro que están muchos
cuestionamientos acerca de cómo se
podría llevar este proceso de paz
la opinión de Alejandra desde la ciudad
de Monterrey le doy ahora la palabra a
Pamela en la ciudad de Barcelona en
España Pamela Gracias por estar con
nosotros Bienvenida al debate de France
24 y el mismo Punto de partida Cuál es
su análisis estamos en el inicio en los
primeros pasos de una ruta hacia la paz
de yemen
Bueno también agradecer la invitación a
participar en el programa y el poner el
foco no en un contexto
invisibilizado habitualmente
en la agenda mediática internacional yo
creo que sí que efectivamente podemos
hablar de que hay estamos en un punto de
inflexión es un punto relevante pero
también por la convergencia de distintos
procesos no yo creo que es importante
recalcar que desde el año pasado la
firma de un acuerdo de al fuego que si
bien no se no se prolongó Más allá del
mes de octubre formalmente en la
práctica si se ha mantenido Y eso ha
llevado una reducción significativa de
las hostilidades en en el último año
y reduciendo también los impactos de la
violencia en la población que es que
recordemos es la principal víctima de
este conflicto armado
reduciendo también los niveles de
letalidad Tal como se mencionaba en el
inicio del programa ha habido acuerdos
relacionados con el intercambio de
prisioneros que también forman parte de
las medidas de confianza que ha estado
intentando promover Naciones Unidas y a
día de hoy también está en marcha todo
el proceso no de conversaciones directas
entre árabes Saudita y los hootis que
son no uno de los protagonistas dos de
los principales protagonistas de de este
de este conflicto armado y yo creo que
eso en en el marco no de esta
restablecimiento de anuncios
restablecimiento de relaciones también
entre Irán y Arabia Saudita que son
países que han jugado un papel muy
relevante en en esta cuestión invitan a
dibujar un nuevo panorama pero yo creo
que hay que tener muy en consideración
de que de que hay que implicar a otros
actores que no se deberían quedar fuera
de este proceso Quiénes pueden ser
entonces esos otros actores que deben de
implicarse en este en este proceso
justamente para ya iba mi pregunta
Pamela Cómo aprovechar Entonces esta
coyuntura que está viviendo el país con
estos aspectos que ya hemos puesto en el
panorama de lo que está sucediendo quién
más se debería involucrar allí por lo
menos la visibilidad internacional en el
conflicto y en este proceso en esta
coyuntura de relativa calma está
empezando a tomar fuerza entre los
medios internacionales ya eso es un
avance
Pamela Sí Por cierto esto es un avance y
yo creo que que estamos siguiendo muy de
cerca no la evolución de la de estas
conversaciones entre Arabia Saudita y el
grupo aludista pero sí que desde
Naciones Unidas también se está
enfatizando la necesidad de incorporar
otros actores no que son parte de estas
distintas capas que conforman el
conflicto armado yemení que recordemos
un conflicto complejo multifacético y yo
creo que hay que recalcar sobre todo la
importancia de implicar a actores no
armados en todo el proceso actores de la
sociedad civil que han estado planteando
una serie de demandas relacionadas con
la rendición de cuentas con la necesidad
de justicia transicional en el marco de
cualquier proceso de paz y enfatizaría
también principalmente la necesidad de
implicar de manera activa igualitaria y
sustantiva a las mujeres yemanías que
han estado reivindicando durante todos
estos años una participación en los
procesos formales de negociación y que
han sido sistemáticamente excluidas y
marginadas en todas las distintas
instancias que se han activado en estos
años claro Alejandra su opinión sobre
estos actores que deben también ser
incluidos su opinión sobre este tema
Sí yo creo que coincido coincido con
Pamela en el sentido que sí se tienen
que para que sea un proceso de paz tiene
que venir de abajo hacia arriba y por
eso es que los anteriores acuerdos de
paz que venían de de arriba hacia abajo
habían fallado Y en este sentido Pues de
yemen se encuentra muy dividido ya era
un país dividido antes de de los
movimientos de protesta en el 2011 Por
una parte tenemos lo que es lo que era
considerado la parte sur o la parte de
la República democrática y yemen del
Norte
y en ese sentido los países del Consejo
de cooperación del Golfo han logrado
armar
un gobierno una especie de consejo de
gobierno transicional con la finalidad
de que ellos hagan frente a estas
negociaciones y se incluyen en este
consejo personalidades que van desde
las fuerzas militares
personajes que tienen que ver con el
liderazgo que se ejerce en los
territorios porque acordemos que además
por por los grupos electricidad la la
diversidad étnica y religiosa que
existen yemen Pues también estos grupos
están incluidos y lo que se quiere de
momento es que aprovechar este periodo y
tratar con Naciones Unidas de llevar a
cabo este proceso sin embargo pues hace
el interior de estas
representaciones hay también personas
que no están de acuerdo que no quieren
ceder ante los judíos y que tienen
todavía una serie de demandas que ellos
consideran que no podrían ser alcanzadas
a través de este mecanismo
es un país dividido También tenemos la
presencia de de al qaeda en la parte
este Entonces eso Por una parte no que
tiene que ver con un acuerdo de Paz
donde participen personas de la sociedad
civil líderes de la sociedad civil que
sea inclusivo para que funcione a largo
plazo pero también aquí hay un problema
este y que también se mencionó al inicio
del programa y que tiene que ver con la
infraestructura con la economía también
a principios de años se convocó a una
reunión a nivel multilateral para lograr
financiamiento a esta cuestión económica
y la cantidad reunida quedó muy por
debajo de la meta que eran de cuatro mil
millones de dólares se quedó solamente
Aproximadamente en un poco más de un un
millón
siendo siendo sin duda llama la atención
que no haya tenido esa esa facilidad
para recaudar ese dinero Alejandra
siendo un país que está en un punto
estratégico de las rutas de navegación
internacional el prácticamente en la
puerta del canal de sueso El más rojo
también pues conecta múltiples rutas en
esta parte del océano Índico es un punto
estratégico para la navegación
internacional y es un punto importante
para el tránsito de barcos también allí
Alejandra Pamela a mí me parece
importante poner un poco en contexto
para terminar esta primera parte un poco
la historia que ha tenido este país ha
sido un país sumamente violento con un
pasado muy complicado un país dividido
que a partir de los 90 logró una
reunificación de dos estados separados
completamente distintos con dos visiones
de país muy distintos un pasado colonial
o de protección por parte de los
británicos pero también en el pasado fue
parte de los otomanos una relación de
tiro de afloje con Arabia Saudita y es
un punto de conexión también con África
tiene mucho también de este continente
es
es un punto muy muy particular pero muy
convulso a lo largo de los años por qué
a yemen Alejandra le ha costado tanto
mantenerse Unido como país y mantener la
estabilidad política
Bueno como tú como tú bien dices esto se
debe a la historia a la historia de
yemen no en la parte Norte con un
especie de imanato este con una especie
también de legitimidad propia religiosa
o características tribales y luego a un
Sur que siguió un un periodo este
socialista que después se viene con la
unificación es un país que fue creado
este artificialmente no como muchos de
los otros países que tiene una relación
cultural histórica y estratégica con el
cuerno de África que por cierto también
algunos países como emiratos árabes
Arabia Saudita tiene los intereses
puestos en el cuerno de África entonces
este país sí ha atravesado por periodos
de conflicto que tienen que ver con el
carácter étnico con la influencia de
actores particularmente con Arabia
Saudita es un país que se encuentra al
sur con un alto nivel
estratégico para Arabia Saudita para el
resto del mundo y pues yemen ha
atravesado después de la unificación
pues ha atravesado diferentes momentos
que
pues han visto nuevamente intentos de de
separación nunca ha estado nunca ha
estado del todo Unido ha habido ha
habido intentos y han celebrado
elecciones pero Pero ha habido
diferencias con los diferentes partidos
principalmente el islag el partido
reformista y las fuerzas este seculares
las diferencias entre el norte y el sur
y bueno Y también algo que que no se
debe descartar pues es como también lo
mencionabas que yemen es uno de los
veinte países más pobres del mundo claro
antes de las protestas árabes sí que
tiene muchos problemas a nivel económico
y bueno la estabilidad ya le voy a dar
la palabra Pamela solamente quiero
anotar que previamente para poner en
contexto a la gente estaba dividido en
dos la República árabe de yemen que
estaba al norte y la República popular
democrática de yemen que estaba al sur
es y luego en los 90 lo unificaron en un
solo país llamado yemen que es el país
que conocemos al día de hoy Bueno hecho
importante que ha tenido lugar hace
algunas semanas llamó mucho en la
comunidad internacional esta noticia
Pamela y es justamente ese reinicio de
relaciones entre Arabia Saudita e Irán
países que se disputan la relevancia o
la presencia en esa área del Golfo con
dos vertientes muy distintas a nivel
religioso de ahí viene su choque porque
tienen pues dos miradas muy distintas de
la región islámica entonces ahí hay
confrontaciones pero Qué tan importantes
son este este restablecimiento de las
relaciones para yemen uno pensaría que
no tiene nada que ver
bueno claramente en este caso sí que
tiene muchísimo que ver porque
si bien el origen de la disputa en yemen
no no tiene que ver con esta disputa
regional que yo más que una cuestión
religiosa la atribuiría a una
competencia por el poder no Y la
influencia en la región
en el caso de yemen está está contienda
así que se ha visto directamente
influida no por la participación de
estos dos actores regionales recordemos
que en el año 2015 árabe Saudita
intervino en yemen liderando una
coalición internacional
con la intención de restablecer al
gobierno internacionalmente reconocido
que había sido derrocado y de puesto no
por por el grupo de los cutis y en parte
es no su decisión de involucrarse en
esta en este conflicto y en esta en esta
contienda que hasta entonces tenía un
carácter más bien eminentemente interno
estuvo también muy determinada por esta
percepción de competencia y Riviera con
con Irán y la percepción de que los
cutis eran de alguna manera un un grupo
próximo no vinculado a Irán debido sobre
todo a
algunas características ideológicas de
los budíns que lo hacen más vinculados a
una práctica del propia del sismo una
que es mayoritario en en Irán
en realidad en ese entonces había mucha
especulaciones sobre la relación
efectiva que existía entre Irán y los
cutis y se se ha reflexionado mucho No
hasta qué punto se ha convertido en una
profecía autocumplida en el sentido de
que el propio conflicto y el devenir de
esta intervención de Arabia Saudita lo
que ha hecho es propiciar un
fortalecimiento de las relaciones entre
los y el gobierno de Teherán
aunque los utis defienden tener una
agenda propia reconocen también que sí
que es tu vínculo se han estrechado con
Irán y bueno Irán ha sido señalado
también por por no estar apoyando y
proveyendo de armas a a este grupo
armado por lo tanto
la noticia no de este restablecimiento
de relaciones que que genera un nuevo
marco para el diálogo no entre estas dos
potencias regionales de alguna manera
se ha considerado como un marco que
puede favorecer el entendimiento entre
algunos de los principales actores en
yemen pero no es y es importante decirlo
no es no es necesariamente
un contexto que favorezca las resolución
de de este conflicto porque como decía
previamente este conflicto tiene varias
capas y hay una serie de
diferencias y de y de disputas internas
que requieren ser abordadas en
profundidad para poder hablar de
realmente una construcción de paz
efectiva y sostenible en yemen a largo
plazo claro creo que Pamela ha expuesto
muy bien el el tema de la presencia de
Irán y la relación que tiene con este
conflicto pasó entonces a preguntarle a
Alejandra por el papel que tiene Arabia
Saudita que es el país vecino del norte
de yemen además las dos caras
completamente distintas de la moneda
yemen un país sumamente pobre con
muchísimas dificultades y el otro lado
de la frontera Arabia Saudita un país
exportador de petróleo sumamente rico
desarrollado tecnológico avanzado dos
contextos completamente diferentes aquí
que tiene que ver Arabia Saudita en este
conflicto
Bueno yo quisiera empezar un poco
retomando algunas cuestiones de la
pregunta anterior y que efectivamente
después de las protestas árabes la
dinámica
regional y extra regional con actores
involucrados como
Estados Unidos y Rusia pues vino a
marcar lo que algunos académicos y
analistas llaman la Guerra
Fría árabe donde
la el eje principal de esta guerra
estaba entre Irán y Arabia Saudita con
este acuerdo
Se supone también que va a haber un
cambio en esta dinámica de de guerra
fría donde como mencionaba Santiago al
principio también se esperan cambios a
partir de este acuerdo y los acuerdos
entre Irán y Arabia Saudita que no se
conocen a detalle que esto vaya a tener
también implicaciones para lo que sucede
en Irak para lo que sucede en Líbano y
también en la relación con el propio
Israel no que tanto el gobierno de de
biden como
querían o buscan el acercamiento de
Arabia Saudita con Israel
Bueno entonces ahora el papel de Arabia
Saudita con respecto a yemen siempre ha
sido como una especie si te permiten la
comparación
con con pinzas pero un poco es la
frontera que es muy importante como la
frontera entre México y Estados Unidos
no siempre esa frontera va a ser
importante Arabia Saudita siempre ha
estado involucrada con los diferentes
grupos tanto con líderes tribales del
Norte Como con el islag ha sido su
principal Aliado y entonces pues Arabia
Saudita siempre ha estado siempre ha
estado presente y creo que tanto Arabia
Saudita como los países miembros del
Consejo de cooperación van a estar
presentes en este proceso y como bien
dijo Pamela o sea lo que tiene que pasar
aquí es que se involucren a todos los
los actores
la parte externa y sobre todo el papel
de Arabia Saudita pues traten una de
alguna manera de frenar sus incursiones
para que este proceso de paz sea posible
y de hecho ya anunció junto con emiratos
árabes un paquete de ayuda a a yemen
Entonces yo creo que el papel de Arabia
Saudita si bien no es no es lo mismo los
actores internos de yemen que tienen que
participar en este proceso de paz si
sigue siendo y va a seguir siendo un
actor importante a largo plazo claro no
solamente porque tener la capacidad
económica de ayudar junto con los
emiratos árabes es un país vecino es un
país que también le interesa la
estabilidad de de la región y también
porque ha habido muchas críticas
internacionales a raíz de que en el 2015
Arabia Saudita ejerció un bloqueo a
yemen entonces y podía importar comidas
y muchos productos
a través del territorio de Arabia
Saudita y es uno de los tantos factores
que ha desencadenado esta crisis
humanitaria por lo menos esa casi
hambruna la que cayó este país a lo
largo de Tantos meses Pamela regreso con
usted a la ciudad de Barcelona usted
mencionaba algo importante y son esas
disputas internas las disputas
regionales y las disputas que hay en las
diferentes capas que componen a yemen
Quiero que profundicemos en esto allí
porque pues para entender este proceso
este posible proceso de paz que podría
comenzar en cualquier momento
Si siguen marchando las cosas como van
pues tiene que comenzar desde lo desde
el fondo del conflicto entendamos
entonces Cuáles son esas disputas
regionales internas
Pamela Perdón que perdí lo último el
último audio del quiero que hagamos un
análisis de esas disputas internas
dentro de yemen dentro de los diferentes
actores que hay pero al interior del
país hablábamos de los actores
internacionales ahora pasamos a los
actores dentro del país Sí sí Bueno mira
tal como como exponía Alejandra también
en una de sus respuestas lleven desde
antes del proceso de revuelta ya estaba
no afectado por la coexistencia de
distintos focos de conflictos no marcado
por el tema está de la división
norte-sur hay sectores en el país con
una agenda secesionista no Y eso también
marca alguno de los ejes de tensión en
el interior del del país el país ha
estado también marcado por una presencia
de al-qaeda que es un grupo armado que
ha estado activo en el país
desde los noventas pero que ha tenido
una mayor presencia
sobre todo del 2009 de la fusión de las
ramas saudí yemení de este grupo armado
pero que de alguna manera ha quedado
absorbido no por las distintas dinámicas
del del conflicto armado y y esta
disputa digamos que ha quedado más
invisibilizada Hay también una una una
un eje importante vinculado a
no a la a la a la animadversión entre
distintos actores no tribales actores
políticos hacia los aludistas Pero y
allí También recupero alguna de las
ideas de Alejandra que que planteaba que
de alguna manera se han intentado hacer
esfuerzo promover iniciativas para
intentar articular a este bando anti
alutista pero con lo que lo que hemos
visto en los últimos años es que existen
muchísimas diferencias en las agendas
que tienen cada uno de los de estos
grupos que hacen muy difícil no
articular una agenda común o incluso que
se plantea a de hoy que sean capaces
como articular un conjunto de demandas
en previsión de que en el futuro haya la
posibilidad de sentarse en la mesa no
cara a cara con los alutistas Y en este
sentido quizás Solo destacaría que que
por ejemplo la posición de los sectores
accionistas y de y de los actores
políticos vinculados al sur del país se
han visto fortalecidos
en parte por el apoyo que han recibido
de admiratos árabes Unidos que es otro
actor regional que ha tenido una
implicación directa y y bastante
destacada en el conflicto armado y que
de alguna manera
ha tenido también un pulso interno
regional con Arabia Saudita en términos
de como influenciar en alguno de los
actores locales que están involucrados
en esta contienda y que ha contribuido
no esta disputa también a esta
fragmentación territorial que se ha
instalado en el país y que ha convertido
que a día de hoy el territorio esté
marcado por distintas áreas de de
controlando sobre todo la zona norte del
país más allá de su feudo habitual está
controlando desde el 2014 también la
capital la zona de adén y del está más
más controlado por el gobierno
internacionalmente reconocido no pero
ahí dentro de esta zona también hay
áreas de influencia No claro algunos más
vinculados al sector del sur otros al
partido isla y otros a las fuerzas más
vinculadas al anterior presidente Javi
bueno Alejandra desde su análisis
tomando lo que dice Pamela estas
diferencias en las agendas en las
necesidades y también en los intereses
de los diferentes actores que tan
difícil puede ser poner de acuerdo en
una agenda común para enrutarla hacia la
paz en un país que los antecedentes que
muestran su historia y el pasado es que
siempre ha habido divisiones siempre ha
habido desacuerdos incluso ha estado
debido al país precisamente por tener
miradas distintas aquí será posible
lograr una agenda común como lo ve usted
yo yo sí lo lo considero si lo considero
difícil porque sí está muy muy dividido
como como bien lo lo ha venido afirmando
Pamela
son capas y capas de divisiones aparte
de años pero yo creo que ahorita y ahí
en este sentido lo veo con luz positiva
que hay la voluntad tanto de los actores
externos me refiero aquí a Arabia
Saudita a emiratos árabes está este pues
el acuerdo que logró Naciones Unidas con
este intercambio con el cese de fuego
Entonces yo creo que ahorita son
conscientes de empezar a mover Y tratar
de crear una agenda en común y más que
nada con estos años de guerra yo creo
que la necesidad ahorita es pues acceder
a satis las necesidades básicas y que a
lo mejor esto puede permitir cuando
menos un diálogo que a la larga sea
posible
concretar una agenda con demandas que
favorezcan a todos los grupos o que se
sientan incluidos y representados en
estas negociaciones de paz a mí me sigue
quedando una duda Pamela hemos hablado
de los actores regionales de estos
actores a nivel interno en yemen pero me
sigue quedando una duda en cuanto a la
comunidad internacional lo decía al
inicio del programa que no es una guerra
que tenga un gran despliegue mediático
como si lo tuvo la guerra en Siria como
si lo tiene la Guerra de Ucrania como si
lo tienen otros conflictos Como por
ejemplo
el de Libia o bueno en su momento el
Líbano Por qué en este país la comunidad
internacional no ha prestado tanta
atención siendo un país estratégico a
nivel económico para muchos y de
sumamente importancia
por su ubicación Pero por qué la
comunidad internacional no le Presta
atención y por qué todavía no ha
empezado a involucrarse más teniendo
este escenario que podría favorecer una
coyuntura rumbo a la paz
si me permites solamente quería apuntar
algunas cuestiones adelante la pregunta
anterior Claro que sí porque como vengo
no del ámbito de la construcción de paz
Yo creo que sí que es importante no
poner en valor las posibilidades de de
un acuerdo Yo creo que es un acuerdo en
este contexto es muy difícil pero
obviamente no es imposible
Y eso también porque es de remarcar que
no existe una solución militar al
conflicto armado en yemen se requiere
una solución política y en ese sentido
yo quizás también recordaría y pondría
en valor que yemen fue el único
escenario
no que estuvo que fue escenario de
revueltas no en este marco de las
revueltas de la llamada Primavera árabe
donde hubo una transición pactada y
donde se produjo una iniciativa de
diálogo nacional que durante más de un
año genera muchas expectativas positivas
no como un foro un espacio donde
realmente hubo muchísimos actores
yemenías implicados para discutir las
diferencias en el país es un proceso que
generó además una serie de
recomendaciones que al final no se
pudieron concretar porque el proceso
acabo de recarrilando no pero estas
luchas de poder intestinas pero sí que
hay no un hay experiencia de este
diálogo que no que se tienen que que
poner en valor que se tienen que
rescatar y como que evitaría no esta
sensación de que aparezcamos como
retratando o que de la sensación de que
los niños no son capaces no de dialogar
ni de discutir desde la sociedad civil
también se viene reivindicando desde
hace mucho tiempo poner en el foco las
necesidades de la población
y bueno volviendo a la pregunta que
planteaba sobre el tema de de la
atención mediática la atención
internacional a este caso la verdad es
que ahí a veces cuesta no poner en en
dimensión
este este tipo de situaciones porque sí
que es menos un caso que ha tenido un
acompañamiento internacional en la
última década no todo este proceso del
que me habla del día con loca nacional
contó con un acompañamiento de Naciones
Unidas es un país que ha estado en el
foco de atención por ejemplo de Estados
Unidos en parte porque
a considerar lo considera como un país
estratégico y como como no por su la
actividad al qaeda en el país siempre ha
estado entre sus prioridades
estratégicas pero yo creo que también
aquí es un país donde al final se ha
visto muy condicionado no por
las posicionamiento de los países en
relación a los dos grandes potencias
regionales que han estado involucrándose
en el conflicto en este caso Arabia
Saudita e Irán y muchas de las
posicionamientos de los actores
internacionales
en primer lugar condicionados por esta
relación no yo creo que eso por un lado
yo creo que por otro y creo que además
porque es un tema que creo que es
importante señalar
que ha habido muchos intereses también
en términos de económicos y de ventas de
armas no recordemos que a pesar de no lo
que se ha ido señalando y de la
responsabilidades de todos los actores
armados en vulneración a los derechos
humanos y Incluso en la evidencias de
comisión de crímenes de guerra que se
han continuado vendiendo armas no a este
a los actores protagonistas incluyendo
árabes Saudita que ha sido
responsabilidad como como la no por la
mayoría de las víctimas civiles del
conflicto según muchas muchas
investigaciones y yo creo que ese todo
conjunto de cosas también condicionan no
la la canción y un último factor perdón
porque yo creo que también importante
mencionarlo
también Creo que es por la localización
geográfica no y el tema de los
desplazamientos forzados de población en
el caso de yemen se han restringido
sobre todo a las propias Fronteras del
país la mayor parte de los
desplazamientos a pesar de involucrar a
muchas personas han sido internos y no
ha habido por ejemplo
llegadas masivas de personas refugiadas
a Europa como hemos visto en otros
conflictos que sí que han motivado que
la comunidad internacional o algunos
actores o en este caso Europa
sí que haya haya tomado un partido de
una manera más evidente en Casos como no
sé Siria Ucrania por ejemplo Claro si
hay que decir que en un momento yemen
era un punto de tránsito para personas
que venían del cuerno de África que
trataban de llegar a Arabia Saudita y a
países del Golfo cruzaban las costas
desde eritreya o desde somalia las
costas del mar rojo para cruzar a yemen
o a través de las costas del Golfo de
adén y de ahí continuaban su su camino
incluso algunos de ellos hasta Europa a
través de Turquía en caminata por por
toda la Península arábiga me queda un
minuto para finalizar el programa por
favor muy puntual Sé que es difícil
hacerlo pero se puede lograr las
conclusiones de lo que puede venir para
este país en este intento de diálogo en
este escenario a favor de de un cese de
hostilidades Alejandra comienzo con
usted muy puntual por favor
rapidísimo yo creo que este es un un
punto de arranque y lo tenemos que ver
como tal que existe la voluntad que
existe también ya la claridad que no se
va a alcanzar una paz a través de el
movimiento armado con lo militar tanto
para los actores externos como para los
internos y esto puede poner en marcha el
proceso de paz Gracias Alejandra Pamela
su conclusión para el cierre Bueno yo
creo que hay un conjunto de Señales no
que indican un escenario propicio para
un proceso de paz para una negociaciones
reducción de la violencia disposición de
actores principales a negociar y
involucrarse en un proceso y señalaría
solamente el riesgo de que
los algunos de los acuerdos entre
algunos de actores como los árabes
auditores absolutistas no se presenten
como hechos consumados al resto de
actores que este proceso se abra para la
participación de los diferentes actores
de la sociedad en el marco de un proceso
inclusivo pues Pamela Alejandra
Muchísimas gracias interesante este
análisis un conflicto muy alejado de la
realidad latinoamericana que hemos
puesto aquí en perspectiva para tratar
de entender por lo menos lo básico que
llevó a este país a este escenario en el
que se encuentra Y cómo puede salir de
este conflicto Muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros y gracias a
ustedes también por la sintonía en
nombre de todo el equipo técnico Les
agradecemos haber estado con nosotros la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y de Keyla maestre y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
nosotros
[Música]